[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight President Trump gave his
first State of the Union address the
first official one anyway last night you
probably saw it the striking thing about
this speech was how normal it seemed how
ordinary it was president stuck to the
script pretty much to the letter the
result was squarely in the center of
American public opinion
you heard broad appeals to national
unity calls for strong borders a robust
military you heard warm words for the
country's bedrock institutions from the
family to our democratic process outside
the faculty lounge most Americans liked
these things they agree with them Donald
Trump remains controversial as a person
but the bulk of his positions are not
controversial not very check the polling
on that and that may be the key thing to
know about our current politics it's
mostly personal if you read a Trump
speech and a British accent pretty much
everybody would applaud not everybody
but most people well maybe unfortunately
for all of us last night State of the
Union was not delivered in a British
British accent Democrats did not applaud
in the modern democratic party
everything Donald Trump says is hate
speech even the things the left once
agreed with yes
Trump has changed the Republican Party a
lot has been written about that but not
nearly as much as his administration has
changed Democrats if you just returned
from a year abroad prepare yourself you
will not recognize the new democratic
party last night Democratic members
refused to stand or clap when Trump
raised the national anthem when he
praised military veterans when he
pointed out new low black unemployment
numbers some refused to stand for Steve
Scalise Louisiana congressman who was
nearly murdered last year by a Bernie
Sanders supporter so what is going on
here well obviously they're giving Trump
the finger bad manners are now a form of
resistance but what if it's more than
that what if Democrats actually don't
like those things anymore what if
praising our veterans or a flag really
does enrage the modern left one a tweet
during the speech MSNBC host Joey Reid
put it this way quote church family
police military the national anthem
Trump trying to call on all the tropes
of
50s era nationalism the goal of this
speech appears to be to force the
normalization of Trump on the terms of
the bygone era now think about that for
a minute
church family police military and love
of country are now merely quote tropes
from a bygone era most Americans
consider those things the pillars of our
civilization and if you don't agree with
that
imagine society without those things
what would it look like how long could
it last would you want to live there joy
Reid would so would many of her
co-anchors over at MSNBC in our Harvard
classmates and apparently most of the
Democratic caucus on Capitol Hill Church
family police military those words
disgust them this isn't a political
resistance it's not about Donald Trump
it's nihilism the mindless impulse to
tear down which he did not build its
rage at your father translated into
political terms a politics that elevates
all that is ugly and decadent and seeks
to undermine the decent and the
beautiful and all that came before this
isn't a philosophy it's a sickness and
once you catch it you're apt to say
things like this it gives a speech
tonight in which he makes it sound like
the biggest issue in the United States
are the biggest threat is ms-13 a gang
nobody that doesn't watch Fox News has
ever heard of for this president to
conflate the dreamers with gang members
he was demonizing our immigrants here
and I was offended
so ms-13 is merely something that Fox
News created to demonize immigrants
presumably those would be the very same
immigrants that gang routinely kills
because they only kill immigrants we
don't want to think the left really
believes any of this we're starting to
suspect they really do
Joe Concha writes about media for the
hill and he joins us tonight so Joe over
on another cable channel one of the
contributors said that she was in effect
triggered by the word family in the
speech that was offensive maybe it was a
dog whistle or a code word for something
else what did you that that to me kind
of crystallized the response what was
your view of it the view overall was who
you gonna believe are you gonna believe
polls that were taken by people from
people from across the country by CBS
and CNN I get their flash polls you can
only hold them and so
much wait maybe a couple more
Republicans watched last night that
answer to this poll that I don't think
it's scooted that much so you either
believe then or you believe pundits that
primarily do their pontificating from
studios in New York and Washington and
almost never venture out and all I could
think of was 2016 in the election in
Wisconsin in Pennsylvania in Michigan
and the fact that no one got anything
close to getting those states right in
terms of that blue wall coming down
because no one can gauged through pulse
of the country so we see the analysis
today Tucker and last night and then we
compared it to polls that have just
astounding numbers as CNN saw its
respondents say the speech was very or
somewhat positive it goes higher in CBS
it goes to 75% but here are two key
stats 8 and 10 and the CBS poll who
watched felt that the president was
trying to unite the country rather than
divide it yet all we heard from pundits
was that this was a gloomy and divisive
speech and finally out of the CBS poll
put the partisans aside those who
identify as independents 73 percent saw
this speech as positive but if you've
never heard about these polls and you
watched the coverage today you would
think that this was one of the worst
most divisive most darkest speeches most
darkest as a double- darkest speeches
that we have ever seen from a president
it's almost as if there's a disconnect
between the public and the people are
supposed to be gathering its news and
presenting reality to them well yes I
mean look at joy Reid and her saying
that ms-13 is a Fox story I think she
got her ethnic stump it's an FBI story
as in there on the FBI list it's not
like this is just a gang that you could
put together a football team with there
are 70,000 members in ms-13 in Long
Island not too far from me here in
Jersey they committed twenty five
murders according to local authorities
since 2016 that's a big deal when you
wonder I mean if you dig down a little
bit how many of those murders were
people in your neighborhood or mine
let's see zero how many were of fellow
Salvadoran Guatemala and Honduras
immigrants a hundred percent of them so
how was it anti-immigrant to oppose a
gang that kills immigrants well it kind
of contradicts that what the president
said the week before which was he
extended his docket proposal
to 1.8 million people I mean that that
is far more than the 800,000 that we
have been hearing so how can he propose
something like that and the
anti-immigrant at the same time it's a
walking contradiction Tucker so you've
got a wonder I mean is there anyone
who's in these networks who's thinking
through what life after Trump might look
like I mean if you a lien ate half the
country or devalue your credibility with
all the country because they have what
happens when he's gone oh boy it's gonna
be a complete disaster I would say I
mean the only reason why ratings are a
little bit higher and being propelled is
because of Donald Trump and obviously
their betrayal towards him and I think
what's happening now and I honestly
believe this that you have a lot of
pundits particularly Republican pundits
that are anti Trump that are telling
their audiences on those networks what
they want to hear in essence comfort
food because on their phones afterwards
they're checking Twitter and if they are
even remotely contradictory in terms of
not being anti Trump and we saw saw this
last year with Van Jones after the
president's address to the joint session
of Congress he had praised the president
said he looked presidential and he got
bullied and destroyed on social media to
the point where he had to go back on the
air and say wait a minute let me clarify
what I really said so I think now at
this point you have anchors and pundits
that are very very afraid that their
audiences will turn on them unless they
say exactly what they want to hear and
it's Trump derangement syndrome as well
which you know obviously if you suffer
for that for more than four hours go to
a safe space immediately yeah it's an
airless room and Twitter makes it worse
so thank you for that